*Bruits du train*
Les amis aujourd'hui on est avec Maxenss et on va jouer à un jeu.
Bonjour Maxenss ça va ?
Maxenss : Hey ça va très bien et toi ?
Squeezie : Très très bien on va arrêter ça suffit ! J'lâche ça ! Pour le bien-être de cette vidéo, on arrête !
Aujourd'hui nous sommes sur un jeu qui s'appelle Yasuhati où on contrôle un personnage
...qui va avancer en fonction du bruit qu'on fait.
Il avance quand on parle...
Quand il y a du bruit...
PLUS JE GUEULE FORT, plus son saut sera haut
Voilà vous avez tous compris c'était horrible parce que j'ai dû gueuler et j'me suis écorché les cordes vocales.
T'as d'jà mal ?
T'es prêt ?
"Ahhh (qui augmente en aigu)"
"AH !" (cri très aigu et fort)
*rires*
Très très beau très belle courbe mais attention parce que !...
Oh mais !
"BAH !"
C'est l'histoire d'un petit garçon qui avance très vite dans la forêt il tombe sur un loup il se fait manger la jambe il retourne pleurer chez maman.
"AIIIE !"
Ca fait quand même mal de se faire euh ... couper la jambe a lala qu'est ce que ça fait...
"mal je saigne j'ai mal partout oh mon dieu c'est terrible il faut désinfecter"
*rires*
"OUILLE !"
J'AI MAL A LA JAMBE MERDE !
*ils disent en gros que Maxenss va frapper TRÈS FORT dans les mains quand il faut sauter*
*CLAP*
*AHHH* (très viril)
*rires et paroles incompréhensibles*
J't'ai sauvé !
Et un soir, un autre garçon en sortant de chez lui se fit agresser par un autre homme qui lui morda la jambe il perda sa deuxième jambe c'est alors qu'il finit...
... euuuuh MORT !
Joli sauvetage !
...... y a un homme qui arriva et qui lui mange un bras.
NAN ! NAN ! L'HISTOIRE ÉTAIT TROP LONGUE !
En même temps il était déjà mort...
C'est vrai...
Tic (x600000)
*bruit de train dégueulasse*
*Bruits de train dégueulasse*
*rires*
Mais c'est le train des fois il faut qu'il souffle !
*bruits de train dégueulasses en faisant "Qui ne sautent pas n'est pas "*
*bruits de train dégueulasses*
TATA (x3) (+ bruit de train)
Putain tu fais super bien le train !
TATA (x5)
*bruit de train accompagné de "TATATA"*
ça faut le brûler, faut s'en servir comme allume-feu !
*bruit d'accélération de voiture (VROUM)*
*klaxon chelou*
Ouaiiiis !
Ah ! Allez c'est ça !...
Attends...
*tout doucement* "teeeends"
*klaxon chelou*
NAN ! NAN! MAIS NAN ! IL AURAIT DU PASSER PUTAIN!
*bruit de trompette chelou*
*toujours le même bruit chelou*
NAN MAIS NAN TU M'AS PAS PRÉVENU ! MAIS NAN!
On se croirait sur Arte.
Ouais grave ! Nan vraiment ambiance cheloue !
*Intro de Tracks (une émission sur Arte)*
*toujours le même bruit chelou*
*toujours le même bruit chelou INSUPPORTABLE (c'est du théâtre contemporain ou quoi???)*
OUI !
C'est la ligne d'arrivée ?
Nan c'est... c'est un ennemi !
*ils s'excusent entre eux*
Lucas Hauchard, des hauts de ses 21 ans, aime encore les petites voitures Tomy...
Squeezie : Remet ton bonnet mec
Suivant YouTuber suivant pour la vidéo !
Dis au prochain de venir s'il te plait
Maxenss : Euuuh 'faut que tu viennes apparement ...
Hola
Hola qué tal
T'es un youtubeur mexicain?
Oui je m'appelle Florent Pagny
Salut Florent... Bah nan, c'est un français Florent Pagny
Si, Florent euhhh
Florent Pagno (x3)
Tu sais quoi, je vais aux toilettes, je reviens, je te laisse gérer
OK ça marche
Mama me gusta me gusta el chocolate
Eh ah bambino bambino *trop dure  a comprendre désolé*
Hola qué tal amigos
Hola que tal *vraiment trop dure a comprendre*
*rire*
*meuuuuuuuuh*
*meuuuuuuh*
*rire*
C'est quand tu te marres que ça fait des petits bruits de vache! Mec tu veux que je fasse quoi?!
*Meuuuuh*
*meuuh très bizarre*
*rire*
C'était ridicule, très ridicule
Je n'aurais jamais pensé rire, tu vois, avec une boite à meuh
Moi pareil, je pensais que c'était vraiment l'objet destiné à pas te faire marrer du tout de ta vie
*secouent les boîtes à meuh comme des idiots*
Non non mec ça va, non Maxenss
*Maxenss en pleine crise d'épilepsie...* Non non, Maxenss ça va aller... QUELQU'UN, UN MEDECIN! IL FAIT UNE CRISE!!
Merde je l'ai défoncé
Oh putain il a pété la boîte à meuh! *rires*
Eh viens on étudie ce que c'est
*Générique de C'est pas Squeezie... //HUM HUM// Sorcier pardon...*
Mais dis-moi Jamy, qu'est-ce qu'il se trouve dans une boîte à meuh ?
Ouah la vache !
La vache ! (lol mdr jpp)
What ?
Voilà ce qu'il y a dedans
C'est un anneau, avec un truc en métal.
Et du coup ça fait ce bruit là...
*Générique de C'est pas Squeezie... //HUM HUM// Sorcier pardon...*
*CLAP*
Ah d'accord :/
T'sais pourquoi ça s'appelle "Claque-Doigts" ?
Tout simplement parce que, en fait
tu peux les claquer dans tes doigts. Regarde j'vais...
Maxenss : OH j'me suis niqué l'oreille *rire*
AH j'suis sourd !
*Squeezie qui essaie d'éclater un claque-doigt*
*bruits de claque-doigt*
*rires*
NAAAAAN
Allez on va y arriver on va y arriver
A 2 doigts si j'peux m'permettre
A 2 CLAQUE-doigts
Oooh...
Fais attention....j'te mets pas une...j'te mets pas une claque (Ptn Max t'as bidé)
*PUIIIIN*
*rire de con*
ALLEZ L'OM EU
*CUII CUI CUI*
*CUICUICUICUI*
OUAAHHHLLEZZ
*COOOUUUUUUIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIII*
(Sans doute le meilleur moment de la vidéo mdrrr)
*rires ultimes*
*CUICUUICUII*
Alllez la balle !
*COUIIII*
(mdrr jpp)
C'est le truc le plus pété du monde mon gars c'est scandaleux
T'es sûr c'est pas un déodorant ?
*CUI*
Alors qu'est-ce-que c'est?
*Pfrrt*
Attends que je lance le jeu au moins !
*PFFRT*
*PPPPFRRT*
*rires*
J'avais pas compris au début,
je trouvais ça super bien joué.
Je t'en fais un autre pour voir le bruit qu'il fait?
*..pfrrt..*
Hé pas mal le bruit de celui là (Sarcasme?)
pas mal ouais.
*BOUM*
*Rires*
Tiens fais gaffe mec c'est ultra (pointu) tu touches a peine ça pête
Regard de vicieux de Maxence mdr
A peine je touche ça pête ?
ouais
*BOUM* *Rires*
*PA PA PA PLUSIEUR FOIS*
*BOUM*
*PA PA PA PLUSIEUR FOIS ENCORE*
*PA PA PA PAPAPAPA
Et le plus gros le plus gros ...
*BOUM*
*rire*
*bruit de ballon avec de l'helium*
Non mais mec je suis tellement heureux que tu sois là
Bah franchement c'est un plaisir réciproque
Bah mec mec moi aussi c'est un plaisir partagé mais le problème c'est qu'on a pas lancé le jeu donc euuh on fait ça pour rien
J'ai la tête qui tourne hein moi j'sais pas toi
Est-ce qu'on est pas en train de faire un truc genre pas du tout recommandé
T'sais genre y'a déjà des articles genre "surtout ne faites pas ça"
Allez faut qu'il avance faut qu'il avance plus vite que ça de manière à ce qu'on puisse gagner
J'ai plus d'hélium donc va falloir bombarder SUR LA VOIX bientôt attention oh attention recharge recharge
*Bruit d'air qui souffle*
T'en veux ?
Ouais bah ouais
Allez bien sûr on oublie pas qu'il y a l’ennemi
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH
Naaaaaaan mais normalement on lui saute dessus c'est comme dans Mario il doit mourir
Bah oui logiquement
IL FAUT QUE oh putain mais le bruit du ballon il l'a fait tomber
Ca va ? *rire*
Ca va mon pote tu vas pas tomber dans les pommes ?
Non tranquille (pas de voix d'hélium) *rire*
UN j'met mon survet addidas j'suis prêt à aller bosser
DEUX je vais bosser et là d'un coup on m'appelle le CADEEEEEEEEEEEET
Ok j'suis l'patron parce que je suis pas tombé et on a réussi parce que DANS LA VIE QUAND TU VEUX RÉUSSIR ET BAH TU...
Oh j'étais chaud là
Mais c'était bien franchement on salue la performance
*chantent j'ai tendance à bloquer*
*Instuments chelou*"Est ce que tu m'entends hey ho est ce que tu me sens hey ho Touche moi je suis la hey ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho
*On m'appelle L'Objet Volant Non Identifié de Jul + Trompette* (Si vous êtes sourd et que vous avez le sous titres, dites vous que vous êtes chanceux de pas avoir à subir cette horrible chanson et ecouter pas non plus les autres )
*Maxence S'excite*
Je me suis jamais autant enjaillé sur du Jul
Franchement mec j'étais à fond et mec j'étais à bloc hein
C'est l'un des plus beaux moments de ma vie j'crois
Bon eh bah les amis
*Bruits de train*
Eh bah voilà les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo avec Maxenss
Mec, ça faisait longtemps que j'm'étais pas éclaté comme ça dans une vidéo
ça fait longtemps que j'avais pas autant sué moi aussi
-C'était vraiment *rire*
Tout ce qu'on rêvait de faire les dix premières années de notre vie
Eh bah on les a fait dans cette vidéo
-Clac-Doigts, hélium...
...Bruit de train, petit truc de merde
*POUET POUET*
Enfin bref
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu et à passer voir la chaine de maxenss
Vous y trouverez l'explication de cette coupe de cheveux entre autre
à très vite dans une prochain vidéo, portez vous bien
*Tchou tchou*
*outro stylée (ou pas... #Clash)
Sous-titres réalisés par les abonnés de ce mec (pas) très viril :D